you can easily judge the character of a
man by how he treats those who can do
nothing for him
he who moves not forward
goes backward
many people take no care of their money
till they come nearly to the end of it
and others do just the same with their
time
if you knew how rarely we understood
correctly
you would be silent more often
when a person thinks deeply and
seriously
he has a bad time among the general
public
of all the thieves idiots are the most
harmful
they steal from us our time and mood
everything is hard before it is easy
it's better to make approximately
correct decision than to make a precise
mistake
once you get by achieving your goals is
not as important as what you become by
achieving your goals
if each of us sweeps right under our
feet the whole world will be clean
remember to live
life is too short to drink bad wine
if you treat an individual as he is
he will remain how he is
but if you treat him as if he were what
he ought to be
and could be
he will become what he ought to be
and could be
what is not started today is never
finished tomorrow
doubt can only be removed by action
those from whom we learn are rightly
called our teachers
but not everyone who teaches us deserves
this name
those who stopped loving and making
mistakes have buried themselves alive
the most ridiculous desire is the desire
to please everybody
too many parents make life hard for
their children by trying
too zealously
to make it easy for them
catch a good mood
it so rarely visits us
the greatest evil that can be fall man
is that he should come to think ill of
himself
what is uttered from the heart alone
will win the heart of others to your own
whoever wishes to keep a secret must
hide in the fact that he possesses one
everybody wants to be somebody
but nobody wants to grow
who is the happiest of men
he who values the merits of others
and in their pleasure takes Joy
even as though
were his own
Oblivion is full of people who allow the
opinions of others to overrule their
belief in themselves
Talent is formed in silence
character
in stormy disturbances of light
inspiration is not a herring
pickled for many years
we all of us live upon the past
and through the past we are destroyed
there are people who never make mistakes
because they don't want to do it
he is happiest
he king or peasant
who finds peace in his home
beautiful cannot be known
it must be felt
architecture is Frozen music
there is no past we can bring back by
longing for it
there is only an eternal now that builds
and creates out of the past something
new and better
what we nourish blooms in US
this is the Eternal law of nature
nothing is worth more than this day
give a man a purpose worth living for
and he can survive in any situation
true greatness begins with understanding
your own insignificance
for a man to achieve all that is
demanded of him
must regard himself as greater than he
is
feels his own attractiveness becomes
attractive
magic is believing in yourself and when
you succeed everything else succeeds
to be pleased with one's limits is a
wretched state
divide and conquer is a wise rule
but unite and Lead is even better
love is an ideal thing
marriage is a real thing
one always has time enough
one will apply it well
an intelligent person is not the one who
knows a lot
but the one who knows himself
art is the mediator of what cannot be
said
the best government is that which
teaches us to govern ourselves
we know accurately only when we know
little
with knowledge doubt increases
man's manners are a mirror in which his
portrait is reflected
our friends show us what we can do
our enemies teach us what we must do
Destiny grants us our wishes
but in its own way in order to give us
something beyond our wishes
the intelligent man finds almost
everything ridiculous
the sensible man hardly anything
ingratitude is a kind of weakness
outstanding people are never ungrateful
everyone hears only what he understands
do not give in too much to feelings
are overly sensitive heart is an unhappy
possession on this shaky Earth
go to foreign countries and you will get
to know the good things one possesses at
home
there is no more hopeless slavery than
the slavery of those slaves who consider
themselves free from Fetters
according to the wife chosen by a man
it is easy to judge what he is like and
whether he knows his own worth
character is formed in the stormy
Billows of the world
knowing is not enough
we must apply
willing is not enough
we must do
nothing shows a man's character more
than what he laughs at
no one knows what his powers are until
he uses them
the way you see people is the way you
treat them
and the way you treat them is what they
become
a person lives a real life if he is
happy with someone else's happiness
as soon as you trust yourself
you will know how to live
that which means more
must never be subordinated to that which
means less
the greatest thing in this world is not
so much where we stand
as in what direction we are moving
as per a woman chosen by a man
easy to judge what he is and whether he
knows his price
only he is worthy of life and freedom
who every day goes to battle for it
a person who lies is immediately spot by
his gaze
a person who has something to hide will
rarely look at his companion straight in
the eye
where the light is brighter
the Shadows are thicker
there is nothing in the world more [ __ ]
there is nothing in the world more
shameful
than establishing oneself on lies and
Fables
kindness is the Golden Chain by which
society has bound together
I can tell you honest friend what to
believe
life it teaches better that book or
orator